No, we can't necassarily say Andy's more unpopular, even though he has less
Twitter followers than I have Facebook friends. Because look at the
distributions, they're both different and we can compare them by looking at
them on the scale. In other words, in terms of their unique standard
deviations. This is called standardizing the distributions, using 0 as our
reference point. When we standardize Andy's and my individual scores, I am
further from the mean. Our standardized scores show us the proportion that have
a lower or higher score in that distribution. In the distribution of Facebook
friends, there's a greater proportion of people with more friends than me, than
the proportion of people with more Twitter followers than Andy. So basically
I'm more unpopular.